don't have the meat of the carnivorous
animal like lion tiger dog Pig
Etc and the prophet clearly says all
these animals are prohibited we are
peace loving people therefore we want to
have animals which are
peaceful and countering argument you all
eat plants and you all behave like
plants that is suppression of the senses
a lower species I know scientifically it
is wrong I'm only behaving like a lawyer
I feel ashamed to speak these points as
a medical doctor it's not true that you
eat plants you behave like plants but
the argument he has put forth I'm giving
a counter reply you eat plants and you
behave like plants weak and suppressed
can't move
properly I'm sorry I really apologize I
apologize I have to reply to the
arguments I apologize if I've heard the
feeling of any vegetarian it is not
scientifically true it's just an
argument a counter
argument further he gave the list of
various peace loving people like Mahatma
Gandhi and I respect Mahatma
Gandhi because he has done certain good
things for India and
Humanity but if because Mahatma Gandhi
was peaceful indicates that if you have
veeg food makes you peaceful then today
if you analyze the list of the Nobel
Prize winners for peace almost all or
most of them are
nonvegetarian man and Bean nonv Yasir
Arafat nonv Anar Sadat nonv Mother
Teresa nonv Mother
[Applause]
Teresa I want to ask you a simple
question which man in the history of
humankind is known maximum for killing
maximum human beings can you guess
Hitler Adolf Hitler he has killed 6
million Jews was he a non-v or veg
vegetarian anyhow there are Crusaders of
vegetarians now on the internet if you
go they say see Adolf Hitler was the
vegetarian is a myth he sometimes had
non
W and the other side says that when he
had gastric problems that time you have
vegetable Foods
only to tell you frankly on a scientific
viewpoint point I do not consider the
diet of Hitler to be responsible for him
killing 6 million Jews neither am I
telling irrespective whether you as a
vegetarian or non-vegetarian I'm not
interested in knowing because I being a
doctor I know it doesn't carry any
weight there were other factors which
influenced him to take this drastic step
which is totally inhumane not the
D there are various researches done
there even research in America on a
group of student who are pure non-w and
on a group of student who are wedge pure
wedge and they analyze that the group of
students who were non-w they were less
vient and they were more
social but it's a research it's not a
scientific fact I will never use this as
an argument to prove that non-v food
makes you peaceful no I'm a doctor more
of a doctor as well as lawyer we
required because I'm in a
debate there are researches but these
researches aren't scientific
facts most of the statements what Mr
Rashmi zi made all were researches not
scientific facts there is not a single
authentic medical book which says that
nonv food in general should be
prohibited not a single all the other
researches like the research done by
this person in
America then they say that which food
makes a person intelligent and he gave a
list of great names Albert Einstein and
Isaac newon etc
etc if you analyze the list of the Nobel
Prize winners in all these years
majority of non-v
majority and today
animal behavioral scientists they say
that the carnivorous animal should be
more intelligent than the herbivorous
animal in order to cat the
prey if he's not intelligent how will he
catch the
prey but anyway I'm not going to use
this as an argument therefore nonv food
makes you intelligent because these
things don't actually affect a human
being the diet does affect the human
being but the arguments don't affect the
arguments don't
affect and all the other arguments given
they don't carry weight
actually there are people who give
examples that nonv food makes you strong
is a
myth it's a scientific fact mentioned in
several medical books authentic that
non-v food is good for Health it does
have disease also you can prevent
them there are proteins which I'll come
to it later
on
and to counter argue that they're giving
example of Yun not sing
Nik has any heard of him Yun not sing
Nik in the
Army it is mentioned this book
vegetarian or non-vegetarian Choose
Yourself by gopin Agarwal yadunath Nik
being a vet in the Army in wrestling he
defeated two non-vegetarian therefore
veg food makes you
strong I feel ashamed to reply to these
arguments I feel
ashamed it's a known fact that the title
holders of World Wrestling yes there are
vegetarian wrestlers also but if you
compare with the full
world almost all the title holders of
World Wrestling are
nonv the person known in bodybuilding
maximum who is he and swasher 13 times
World titles you got seven as Mr Olympia
Five as Mr Universe and one as Mr world
what was he veg or
nonv
nonv the box of M cashes CL nonv M Tyson
nonv yes of course non-v food does add
to the strength that is a scientific
fact that's the reason that if you
analyze that when a person is conving
from disease it's preferable non food
not that you have to have nonage it's
preferable egg Etc and I'll come to it
later
on and then they gives an
example of a wrestler Professor ramti
never heard his name he says it's the
world famous wrestler who has heard of
him anyone has heard of him profor Ram
morti no one world famous where you get
this news
from world famous then they give the
example
of perit Singh in London
pure vegetarian who skips 2,000 times a
day therefore vegetarian food makes you
an
athlete if these are the arguments
supposed to be scientific I really feel
ashamed most of the athletic record
holders here's the Guin book you can go
through it I bought it along
here all mentioned about about
bodybuilding bodybuilding athletic 100
met Dash all these
people if at random also you check up
their dietary
history even giving benefit of Doubt
more than 80 to 90% will be non
W but I will be a
fanatic if I say that all these records
are only due to the DS I'll be a
fanatic a few records may be related to
the D but not
for the argument they give that the
smell and the sight of a carnivorous
animal is strong the night vision is
strong as Mr rash said night vision and
sense of smell is strong in caror in
herbes it is less in human being is less
therefore we should be
vegetarian there are her warus animals
like the bee whose sense of smell is
very strong and they even have a very
good night vision see these are
arguments which are not scientific may
be useful in the debate to convince the
people
illogically therefore I'm
here then you give the example you know
animals have hor voice you know Co voice
the carnivorous animal herous animal
don't have Co voice and to ask you a
simple question which animal is maximum
known for a hor voice donkey veg or
nonv veg or nonv
B Anyway by no means am I trying to
prove that vegetarian food creates horse
Voice or non-vegetarian food creates
melodious voice if you see the list of
singers many are nonv many are veg also
so just by quoting singers or V saying
oh that's why vegetarian that makes you
melodious is all illogical arguments
really I feel ashamed all these
things and he gave certain economic
points that economic reasons why we
should have vegetarian food it's more
economical according to Mr
zi and it gave several statistics so
many calories so many this so many tons
of protein which is mentioned here from
where they get the statistics God Alone
knows and he mentioned some protein it's
also mentioned in this book that 1 kg of
animal protein that we get we have to
feed so many plants Etc therefore it's
equivalent to 7 kgs of veeg
protein so if you're having
meat for 1 kg
protein you are taking 7 kg vegetables
therefore vegetable is
cheaper how they get this kg of proteins
I being a medical doctor don't realize
is it kg of food or kg of
protein and if I agree with them I agree
with them you say for sake of argument 2
plus 2 is five I agree and then ask you
that he take two rupees take two rupes
give me 5 rupees take 2,000 take 2,000
give me
5,000 similarly if I agree it is right
all the statistics then I tell that the
vegetarians they should thank the
non-vegetarians you know why because if
he would not have slaughtered the animal
for food it would have lived for another
5 to 10 years and in that time You' have
had the vegetables of seven to eight
people for a few years
so you should thank
us from preventing the animal from
eating your vegetable
food furthermore he gave the calculation
from some record from where I don't
know 1 is to 14 the land that you graze
required for animal is 14 times more
than the land required for food Etc same
example is given here that the land
required to produce one ton of beef the
same land you can feed five average
families one ton of beef is equivalent
to 10 or 20 tons of veg
food and the land required to graze an
animal can raise five average
Families my early argument also holds
good here but besides
that these ideological vegetarians they
fail to realize that the animals Grace
on on land which is unsuitable for
growing
crops they eat the plants which is
inedible for the human beings like husk
and stalks corn
stocks they don't need plants which
edible for the human beings yes they can
eat but when they enter the fields the
farmer but natural takes them out of the
field why to cause loss yeah if have
excess of crop Etc there are certain
governments who even feed them and there
are
nadic
populations who make their living by
grazing animals on land which is
unsuitable for crop growing but they eat
the vegetation which is inedible to the
human beings and they make the living
even the animal lives even the human
being lives and today according to un
report about
23% approximately of the land in the
world is used for pastures 23% for
Forest
less than 10% for cultivation the
remaining 45% majority can yet be used
for growing crops why don't you use that
why are running after the food of the
animals poor living creatures let them
live let them eat why are stopping them
from eating if the non-vegetarians stop
slaughtering the cattle do you know that
there will be overpopulation of Cates
overp population I'm aware that that
human
beings they raise animals for food that
means by methods they increase the
multiplication of animals but if suppose
I agree that from today all
non-vegetarians stop raising animals for
food and stop killing them for food yet
they will grow in population you know
why human beings in all these years our
population is increasing even with all
the family planning method with all the
birth control h yet we increasing there
is no birth control method among the
cats and the gestation is less than the
human
beings 5 months to 6 months to 8 months
less than the human beings and they
multiply faster so if we stop killing
and stop raising yet within a few
decades you'll have problems not of
overpopulation of human beings of
overpopulation of
cats how you going to solve
it there are various nutrition
he talked about protein Etc if time
permits I will speak in the reat I would
like to make a statement of Dr George
rur which is sufficient to counter all
his arguments on health Dr George
rur he is the professor of
nutrition in the University of Texas why
I'm giving the designation you can come
to know that these people actually
specialize in Catching Health fraud
people who deal in fraud in health he
says that virtually all
authors
of the diet and disease books they
propose hypothesis which are
untested ill tested unfound unlikely or
disproved I would like to repeat Dr
George arur says virally all authors
of books on diet and disease they prop
hypothesis which is ill
tested unfound non-tested unlikely or
disproved time is running short I would
like to make the statement that's given
by the American Council on science and
health just a statement see they are
experts these quotation of research
aren't scientific facts all this
quotation that this causes this that
some are scientific facts but they can
be prevented but the other things was
mentioning about this land and that land
these are only statistics done by
individual research
even when you do PhD you can do a
research and that will come into account
but won't carry
weight American cons on science and says
that a person need not abstain from meat
and be a vegetarian to have a healthy
diet and the topic is not veg or non-v
which is healthier it is is non-v food
permitted or prohibited for the human
beings and I will list out the points in
summary to make it easier for Mr zavi to
answer in the
re Point number one there is not a
single major religion which bans or
prohibits all non-v food in general
Point number two geographical
places like Arctic Eskimos live how
could you have provided food all these
years back and today also if you provide
it's going to be more expensive Point
number three if all life is sacred why
do you kill the plants
even they have Life Point number four
even plants feel pain Point number five
even if I agree they have two sentences
L killing a creature of two senses less
is a less of crime is illogical Point
number
six it's preferable to kill one animal
and take one animal life than to take
100 lives of plants for feeding 100
people Point number seven each and every
argument can be disproved the liver and
the kidney HCL
same with saliva same with the pH of the
blood same with the
lipoprotein Point number
eight the human beings have an OM set of
teeth for eating veg as well as
non-w Point number
nine they have a digestive system which
can digest both veg and nonv and have
Pro it scientifically have proved by the
enzymes Point number 10 primitive man
was
nonage you can't say it's prohibit for
human human beings human beings is even
for that
person point number 11 the food you eat
has a effect on a behavior but saying
that non-v food makes you violent has
got no scientific base at all Point
number 12 giving argument that veg food
makes you strong makes you peaceful
makes you intelligent makes you athletes
are all
myths Point number 13 night vision and
sense of smell is strong in Carn
in herbus it is less the Carnivor animal
have horse voice you know Co voice herb
animal don't have Co voice are all
illogical
arguments Point number 14 that veg food
is cheaper I've disproved
it it's not economical in certain
countries yes like India it can be but
if you go abroad in the Western
countries veg food is more
expensive and fresh veg food is
phenomenal fresh
vegetables furthermore Point number 15
that the land required to graze the
animal will cause scarcity of the land
for growing crops is also
wrong Point number 16 if the
non-vegetarians stop slaughtering the
cattle do you know that there will be
overpopulation of
catches Point number 17 according to Dr
Kerr these books written by dietician
they can't relied upon all the
statistics given are mainly from there
there is not a single statement Point
number 18 in any authentic medical book
which says nonv food in general should
be banned Point number 19 there is not a
single
government on the face of the Earth
which has banned all nonv food as a
general
rule and
Point number 20 that even the American
Council on science and health has said
that for a healthy diet being a pure
vegetarian is not
required these are sufficient proof
logical and scientific that nonv food
has to be
permitted if Mr zavi doesn't agree I
request him to answer
scientifically not by comparison on just
researches but but yet if Mr Rashmi by
zi doesn't reply to more than 20 points
which I've put forth yet I will not ask
him to become a non-w because I'm not a
fanatic non-vegetarian I'm not yet if
you want to continue eating vegetan food
I have got no objection it's a personal
choice it's a personal choice some
people like due to certain taste Etc
it's a personal
choice and only thing I'd like to tell
the people that that the vegetarians the
ideological vegetarians who do so much
propaganda that this has got more value
ETA they should stop such things and
stop
Distributing these type of books which
mislead the
people I would like to end my talk by
giving the qu of Glorious Quran from 16
vers 125 he
says that is invite all to the way of th
Lord with wisdom beautiful preaching and
argue with them and reason with them in
the ways that are best most
[Applause]
gracious I now call upon Mr Rashmi B zi
to present his response to Dr Zakir nyak
ladies and gentlemen Mr Rashmi B Zi
[Applause]
first of all I really thank Dr Jakir
nyak for giving me the choice whether I
would like to still remain a vegetarian
or
nonvegetarian thank you very much I
would request uh Mr
coordinator that
uh would you like to have the rebuttal
or my comments now or shall we have
because after all you know this is now
it's better you know we'll let's have
some question answer if you think
question answer we have in the third
session we have three part
session yes Mr Z you can
continue now we are totally at the
command of the coordinator so I will as
decided we know the same format I will
obey I will not allow Dr Zakir also to
change the format object first thing
that I will say it's not a question
of whether one is logical or illogical
and it's not a question of the choice
that one makes as I said in my talk
earlier everything is relative and you
have to understand this topic from that
perspective
now one thing that I will very strongly
object with respect back to Dr Jakir
that not a single religion prohibits
nonv I am expert I can say because I am
a student I have done Ma in genology I
can say from my religious point of view
that Lord mahavir and our all 24 Tunas
very vly prohibited non wage food I have
already given you some quotations you
see mainly arguments of Dr de orish uh
is based on the fact that nonv food
contains excessive protein cholesterol
and saturated fat so that is why he said
that for healthy and peaceful living you
must have non wage
diet
now he said that plant is also got life
no it is not only proved by Dr jish
Chandra BOS but you our Lord mahavir he
stated 2,500 years ago that not only
plant
air water fire minerals of the earth
they all have life he has not said that
you are allowed to kill this life and
maintain yourself but he was a
practical tankar so he said that those
who cannot renounce this world and
become Jan monei you know Jane
munis they don't even kill plant
vegetation or even other living beings
for their food the beg the food which is
cooked in our house will not go into
that controversy that even you kill it
and then give them that's a separate
story but the teachings of mahavir are
very clear that you shall not harm any
living being whether animate or
inanimate now
because of certain constraint for those
people who cannot renounce the world he
has said that at least you can avoid
essential killing he has said that even
if you when you have food made out of
plant it is violence it is hinsa but it
is necessary so what I prohibit is
unnecessary killing friends this is a
very sharp distinction but very
important distinction we should make
that if the alternative is available we
should not go for that alternative which
compels us to kill and eat our own
fellow creatures another thing
so he said
plants in my talk I stated about plant
food and he said that even a lizard can
grow tail that's the only exception the
plants you pluck fruits they will give
you more Roots you cut their branches
more branches will grow see there is no
end to such argument so let us restrict
our argument to this about medical
science and he rightly stated that
medically also he has given certain
things I have also stated now it is for
the enlightened audience to decide
whether the scientific facts that I have
given are correct or he has given it's
okay it's a question of argument now he
has conveniently forgotten please excuse
me I'm telling because I'm trying to re
your things the psychological aspect
when we consume animal food we also
inherit certain animal instincts what
have you to say please in your rebuttal
you can say that now doctors also most
of the doctors prescribe raw vegetable
now coming to cooking most of the
doctors prescribe raw vegetables for
healthy diet only that food or cereals
which will not be proper for a human
being to consume Ro that only can be but
as far as possible and in our Indian
vegetarian Congress we always whenever
we have meeting we have most of the food
row uncooked and that is more healthy
according to
us about the books these books were not
given by me to Dr nyak and it was given
by my friend Mr salacha who approached
me that's okay there nothing very
important now I will tell you one thing
that you cannot altered the truth by
just loud Applause okay if you are
impressed by my argument you may
Applause me or if you are impressed by
the other argument you can Applause that
but I firmly believe that just because
some arguments are appealing to you and
you Applause them loudly will not alter
the truth and
U I will I have referred to about one
book one Dr deak Chopra he has also
written many books he is also a
physician practicing physician like Dr
de ornish he has also conducted
researches and he has come out with a
theory that your food will have a
terrific effect on your impulses and
urges your physical development
psychological development and emotional
development you know most of the
psychological and emotional distortions
are because of the flesh food that one
eats and that is why it is prohibited
it is totally illogical to say that by
eating animals you are helping
vegetarians we should not worry about
the animal population because nature is
quite capable of taking care why
because we are because we are raring
more an animals for killing that is why
there if we are not doing it look at the
jungle everywhere the natural cycle is
there balancing will take care of itself
nobody has to worry about
it now as per the history that Mr tried
also referred and also Dr Jakir now I
will tell from Jan historical point of
view that in our Jane Scriptures it is
mentioned very clearly that the PE those
persons who were living in prehistoric
stage they lived under a tree and they
were sufficiently provided by trees they
did not have to go for any killing
friends I of course given more time but
I I really personally feel that let's
not have a sort of of dialogue or
arguments between I would like very much
the audience to participate and have
more time for question answer thank
[Applause]
you thank you Mr zi we have uh five
minutes more it's taking five minutes
left now I call upon Dr Zakir n to
present his response to Mr Rashmi bavi
for 15 minutes
only
alhamdulillah the respected people on
the DI and my respected elders and my
sisters I welcome once again all of you
with the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa tala be on all of
you I have not conveniently forgotten
anything if you realize I spoke maybe
half minute more than the time allotted
so how can you say I conveniently forgot
if you give me even 5 hours more if
you're willing to
stay because you are the person who kept
time restrictions you know less time 30
I had to bargain for 50 minutes I would
love to speak for 2 hours even full day
I can do it because I'm a marathon
speaker
alhamdulillah I'm a
[Applause]
non-vegetarian Mr zavi
said that I said that no religion
prohibits non-w I never said no religion
I said no major religion it's being
recorded no major religion and jism is
not not a major religion according to
the books you gave me you give certain
books J are only 4% of
india4 less than 1% can you call it a
major religion in India live side world
world out of the question negligible I'm
very clearcut in my statement regarding
the argument on jism I can reply but the
coordinator won't give me permission I'm
restricted to Islam you know I can reply
even on gen them I'm a SP of
comparative excuse me sir you can't
interfere when the speaker speaking
brother is saying I did not say you can
very well see the video cassette there
is not a single major religion which
bans or prohibits all nonv food in
general you can see the video cassette
ask your question in question time
please don't get iritated the diet will
help you don't get
irated brother Rashmi byi said I did not
answer whether you get animal Instinct I
said in my lecture I think you didn't
hear I said we we eat peaceful animals
like goat sheep because we want to be
peaceful and therefore when I came
starting I always said Peace be on all
of
you further he said I didn't State Dr de
Onish I yet challenge him if his book is
referred by any authentic Medical
College authentic book not just dietary
books that answer already gave by Dr
William T Jaris even scientists and
medical professionals are not immune to
the IDE iCal thinking of the vegetarians
they aren't immune it's not a medical
book he may have WR a died book I'm very
clear in my words I don't mix words and
Dean Onish whatever his name is may be
very famous I don't know him I'm hearing
for the first
time I don't know I yet ask him to prove
and check whether that book is referred
as a text book not as a medical book a
text medical book in a college that
shows
authenticity he said we should not worry
about the cattle nature will take care
it is you all who are so much worrying
we aren't worrying Nature Made Them in
such a way that the moment you kill them
they will again come God is the creator
Allah made them if we kill lion tiger
they will become extinct therefore we
cannot have their food the cattle we can
have God has made them that way if we
don't follow the instruction of God
there'll be overp
population and regarding cutting of
plants what he said you know people say
that if you have plants the mother is
yet alive so in that way The Offspring
of the cow of the goat the Cales that
means can we cut them yes mother is yet
alive the cow is it alive and when The
Offspring becomes a mother you can also
kill the mother so even if I agree with
this Logic the plant survives in the
animals more lives are surviving than
the plants if I agree with this
logic furthermore I
said that best is prevention is better
than cure I agree with Dr Onish when he
says that you know vegetarian diet is
helpful for certain disease even I
advise that where I said no but the
topic is not which food is
healthier but making a statement it is
banned for human beings I challenge any
authentic medical book I'm a doctor not
books whether given by Russia Foundation
or indianan congress whatever it is
these books are stating things which are
unfound ill tested unproved
there's the Islamic method of prevention
better than cure which will answer most
of your questions the Islamic method is
there of prevention better than cure
when we sort of animal we do the Zab we
cut the throat and the windpipe and the
vessel of the neck without damaging the
spinal cord otherwise the nerve going to
the heart may get severed there will be
cardiac arest when the spinal cord is
not damaged and the vessels of the neck
are slit open along with the throat and
the wind pipe the heart is pumping most
of the blood flows out of the body blood
is a very good media of German and
bacteria if you Slaughter the animal in
this way most of the Disease transmitt
by Blood many which you named can be
eliminated can be
prevented the meat remains fresh for a
longer time if it's sled by the Islamic
method and people say oh it's a
merciless you know you are so
mercilessly killing it dies of
pain when we sorten the Islamic method
when we cut the blood vessels of the
neck the blood supply going to the nerve
which is responsible for pain is severed
so the animal does not feel pain the
animal kicks and rs you know why due to
the gush of flow the animal doesn't feel
pain it is Contracting and relaxing
because there's lack of blood in that
part of the body the animal does not die
of pain it dies of painless death
painless
painless we eliminate most of the
disease transmitted by Blood secondly
there are many
countries in the world and many people
who raise animals they give them
hormones and one was mentioned by Mr Z
he name it's called as
D diol it's a hormone injected to cattle
so that they become fat and you get more
money for flesh this is Haram in Islam
carcinogenic hormones if ingest an
animal even if you Slaughter by the
zabya method it is yet Haram it is zabya
but not Halal it is zabya and Haram if
the Catt are injected with hormones you
are not allowed to have those hormones
neither are you allowed to have cows
which are fed with non wedge because the
prophet said any animal that is fed with
nonv it is prohibited for
you after that if you take care of
hygienic conditions and cook the meat
very
well most of the diseases which Mr zi
spoke not all most of them will be
eliminated and In the non-w Flesh food
the most dangerous which is commonly
eaten is
poke it has more than 70 different
diseases which you can get if you inest
poke more than 70 different diseases and
one of them is ishemic heart disease
which he spoke about because pork has
more of fat Building Material than
muscle building material it gets
deposited on the walls of the vessels
causing arcis hypertension Etc
that's the reason in the Quran no than
four different places inah Bak chapter
number 2 vers 173 in MA chapter number 5
verse number three in chter number 6
verse number 145 and chter number 16
verse number 115 it
says for for you for food dead meat
blood the Flesh of swine and any food on
which any name besides God's name has
been invoked it's Haram so we abstain
from it and we prevent several diseases
of non-wage Quran says in chapter number
20 verse number 81 eat of the food we
have provided for you in sustainance but
commit no excesses therein most of the
diseases what Mr Rashmi spoke about is
due to excessive eating even if you eat
excessive veg food you will have many
diseases I will not say don't have veg
food I'm a doctor I'm not an ideological
neither a fanatic nonvegetarian
so if you prevent eating in excess most
of the disease will prevented if you
follow the Islamic guidelines Slaughter
in the Islamic method remove the blood
don't give hormones cook the food very
well hygienic conditions avoid poke
don't eat in excess most of the disease
can be prevented it answers most of his
arguments few are yet remaining if time
permits or question answer time if you
ask I will
reply do you know they're talking about
healthy food healthy food talking about
all research and experiments I'll talk
something which is a
fact according to Dr
William again very famous person Dr
William he says that vegetarian food
extends the life of a human being for
more than six years if you have veg food
as compared to non-v food you live 6
years longer again hypothesis
hypothesis if you
analyze a data was collected about all
the people who lived above 100 years
from 1932 to
1952 and on this data a person by the
name of OES he wrote a book living to be
100 1,200 people who did and why they
did it everything is mentioned in it
even diet is mentioned do you know out
of 1,200 people how many were vegetarian
how many
guess 1,000 four
four four
this survey wasn't done to prove veg
food or non-v food it was done for other
reasons but even the diet was mentioned
it's a fact it's not a
research it's a fact out of 1,200 people
who lived in the span of 20 years over
100 years only four were
vegetarian you know alcohol alcohol
alone it is a veg diet or not alcohol is
veg or non- V veg from juices of fruits
and the disease that are caused by
alcohol Al stone is more than all the
non disase put together one vegetable
diet so just for alcohol I cannot say
that all vegetable foods should be
banned today scientist and he agree it's
mentioned in these books also the cause
of Maximum death in the world today is
alcohol number one so I don't ban all
veg food what do I say as Quran says Sur
ma chter number 5 verse number 19
that oh you belief verily intoxicant and
gambling and idol worship and edication
of stones and the Manish of arrows these
are Satan's handwork abstain from it
that you may
Prosper alcohol is a Satan's handwork
abstain from it I only prohibit alcohol
not all W food
and smoking second greatest cause of
death in the world veg or nonv veg can
you prevent the alcoholic disease only
way you can prevent is deferment it it's
easiest to be alcohol can you prevent
smoking disease don't have tobacco only
option is prohibition if there is no
prevention then comes the question of
prohibition so alcohol is prohibited
there are more than 400 fatwas by
Islamic scholar smoking is prohibited
because there no prevention you know
qual
krial Indian government has banned it it
causes paria staple food of
Northwest Indians
banned why it causes death also
paria alcohol many countries have ban
including Saudi Arabia including states
in India have banned it smoking in
Singapore is banned in public places in
government places in public
transport K banned by India if there's
no prevention then you can ban it I do
not know of a single government that has
banned all non-v food in general not a
single yes few non-v food like poke
Saudi Arabia has baned there's no
prevention band it if there's no
prevention then you prohibited and the
debate was not which is better which is
healthier veg or non-v the debate was is
non food permitted or prohibited I gave
a list of more than 20 points so I can
very well say that Mr Rashmi
conveniently stopped his talk 5 minutes
before not to answer these things if you
give me one hour
more I will continue
speaking wild berries they're poisonous
stretch vegetable food they're poisonous
data
poisonous what's the solution don't have
it you know water water has so many
diseases transmitted chera paratyphoid
typhoid it causes amasis gasis round
worm pinworm while hepatitis I can go on
talking only by water
what do you do do you band
water you prevent it you purify the
water the disease will be
prevented you know milk milk has so many
diseases Shiga cha paratyphoid typhoid
tuberclosis Salis brucelosis I can go on
listing what do you do do you band milk
what do you do you pasturize it you
don't ban it you don't prohibit it it's
UNM medical whether milk is nonv or veg
is a debatable
topic I won't argue on
that so if you cannot prevent the
disease then do you prohibit it I have
given various reasons which Mr hasn't
replied there's not a single government
who has banned non-v food in general
there's not a single major religion
which has banned non-v food in general
therefore I say that non-v food is
permitted not prohibited if I've heard
the feelings of any vegetarians while
giving the replies to the speaker I
sincerely apologize from the bottom of
my heart I would like to end the talk by
giving the quotation of the Glorious
Quran from Surah is chapter number 17
verse number 81 which
says when truth is H against falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to
[Applause]
perish e